[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is know what each
other's just joining each other
joining us today is no one but our
voices the voices of rats and mine are
joining your ears in a biscuit that I
hang around yeah you know I don't leave
just because nobody's here we're
following up last month's retinol
retinyl retinol e yes my new podcast
Retton only last month's rhettandlink
only ear bitten out of a phrase just
just sort of let you know you should
probably take that as a you should
probably see that as a sign of like
humility that you try to say a sentence
with your name in it and you left your
name out I think that's a great thing
you should be proud of that you should
do that more often you should take your
name out of more sentences I'm very
humble yeah I think it's a southern
thing too mispronounced the word humble
yeah I know with a silent H anyway what
I was trying to get at was we received
feedback from you guys that you enjoyed
the ear biscuit we did about bizarre
experiments about a month ago yeah
thanks for enjoying that and it was an
experiment to see if you would enjoy it
and now we've gotten your feedback and
you guys said hey let's do it again or
do another rent link only your biscuit
that's kind of topical kind of gmm ish
yeah so that's what we're gonna do today
and I will say I did see if you a cut a
few comments people I really enjoyed
that your biscuit you guys talked about
experiments it was kind of like an
extended GMM but I want you guys to keep
doing stuff where you tell stories and
talk about your lives and not that we're
not going to do that again at some point
but just so you know there is a finite
amount of things that we can say about
ourselves that we haven't already said
in some form we've been on almost 700
episodes of good mythical morning if
you've seen that show because we're no
longer living our lives we're just
making entertainment so we no longer we
don't generate stories anymore you got
that's what that's what link is saying
we don't generate news well not nearly
at the pace so anyway I will say I've
got a story from our past that's
embedded in one of the topics okay that
I'm gonna bring up to Dad's do I so then
you get a little anecdotal stuff living
in Lydda antidote in there but this is a
today we're gonna be talking about is
some of the most intense rites of
passage from cultures around the world
past and present and we're gonna be
focusing on what different cultures see
as ways for boys to become men now
there's there's also writes a passage
out there for women but you know what
we're men who were once boys we like to
think of ourselves as men after reading
about some of these different rites of
passage I like to make a question
whether or not I'm actually a man I like
to think of myself as a a man boy a boy
trapped in a man's body manchild which
is I I think that's better than a man
trapped in a boy's body yeah
probably extremely frustrated yeah
definitely and doesn't sound appropriate
or shouldn't be spoken on yeah you
should have just take it right back but
we're gonna be going through some of the
ones that were the most intense to us
that we will we hope that you will enjoy
and as as it was the case with the
previous podcast the retin link only
podcast it may get a little intense I
don't think it's as intense is like
shocking corpses for did like animate
them in front of crowds I don't think it
gets that intense but it could it might
you never know what's gonna happen I
will commit there will not be any boys
to men
R&B jokes well that was the one you just
made it yeah that's kind of like a
self-referential I won't sing mama
I won't saying that that's the one
you're gonna choose that boys to me
that's what makes it funny man I didn't
say yeah you end of the road I didn't
sing the end of the road or you know I
think you making that joke signifies
you're at the end of the road oh okay so
let's get into some rites of passages in
just a second but first we want to
mention our sponsor EF college Break
they make travel easy affordable and
even more fun for anyone 18 to 28 years
old college not
required traveling around the world is
one of the best things you can do for
yourself especially when you're young 18
to 28 you know it could change your life
these are the experiences you're gonna
have that you're gonna remember the rest
of your life but it's logistical II
difficult to travel right and to
experience the place fully you have to
plan a whole bunch not just flights not
just lodging not just transportation but
you got to figure out where to go what
to see where to see it what's cool to
see what should I avoid and when you
plan your own trip you do all that
yourself or you can let the EF college
break expert travelers do all of that
for you why I let them do it because
it's their job trust me you don't want
to invest the time and effort to do it
half as well as they can they take care
of booking flights lodging
transportation while you're there site
and event coordination and provide you
with a tour director who is a local
expert I have to say local expert in
some sort of random accent I don't know
why well I leave out travel I guess
these built group trips across six
continents with everything from trekking
Machu Picchu cruising the Greek Isles
and immersing yourself in Germany's
Oktoberfest and almost half of college
break travelers sign up solo so even if
you sign up by yourself you'll not be
traveling alone on your trip and not
only will you not be alone you're going
to meet new people potentially make
lifelong friends by sharing a travel
experience with somebody and it doesn't
have to be intimidating to plan a trip
like this outside of the country an EF
college break makes it possible so what
are you waiting for this is your chance
to take that euro trip you've always
wanted how does that sound eleven days
checking out Berlin's nightlife Prague's
gothic atmosphere and Munich's old-world
charm sounds pretty great to me you
can't go like you're not 18 to 28 need I
remind you
your man now you're not a boy anymore
but I'm a boy in a man's a suit a man's
shell I'm in a shell of a man if you are
18 28 we're gonna hook you up with an
extra $100 off your next adventure by
going to our special URL EF College
break.com slash rhett and Link again
$100 off go to EF College break.com
slash rhett and Link we'd also like to
mention Casper mattresses obsessively
engineered american-made mattresses at a
shockingly fair price you spend about a
third of your life sleeping if you're
normal
you better make sure you're doing it on
a good mattress well then I'm super
normal because I do 50% Casper brings
too comfy technologies together for
better nights and brighter days latex
foam and memory foam so they've got just
the right sink in just the right bounce
which interestingly enough is how they
describe me at the club
they also have a risk-free trial and
return policy they deliver it straight
to you you try it for a hundred
eighty-four not happy with it they come
and pick it up it's pretty cool
this is they just sent one to me and I
got to say this is the most trouble-free
mattress experience I have ever had
well even the unpacking of the mattress
because it like comes packaged is an
event in and of itself I should have
been there he comes out like a snake or
like well like a jack-in-the-box or like
a dinosaur that you put into one of
those mmm like a tablet that turns into
a dinosaur that keeps getting bigger but
okay two things to note there a snake
slither and I in it it didn't slither
out of the bug didn't it just kind of
expanded but it's very satisfying second
thing to notice you don't dip the
mattress in water you're going to get it
to eat oh it just came from
oh I'm at the very beginning of my 100
days but let me tell you I don't think
they're gonna be coming to give this one
from me it's $500 for a twin size
mattress 954 king-sized comparing that
to industry averages is an outstanding
price point and now you can get $50 off
any mattress purchased by going to
Casper comm / rhett and Link and using
code rhett and Link Casper comm / rhett
and Link offer code rhett and Link now
on to the biscuit
I used to go dove hunting with my father
and my brother growing up I was never
invited I do remember you coming to
school and telling me and we didn't
trust you with a gun
but and uh I still don't and I will say
and this may be a difficult thing for
many of you who didn't grow up in the
south in the 80s to you know relate to
this but when I was about 10 years old
which is older than my young oldest son
now I had a shotgun in my hands and I
was responsible for shooting birds out
of the air so I would go out with my
brother and my dad and that was a pretty
big deal to me to think that especially
as I think about it now I think about
giving that responsibility to like lock
like we you know we don't hunt as a
family now but to think that I kind of
felt like hours of I was a man but I had
a very powerful machine and I was
shooting a bird of peace out of the air
right it's not really that hard to do
but did you consider it a rite of
passage maybe you didn't use those terms
I felt like I did feel like a man but I
did I think I would have felt different
if I had been faced with what the Maasai
tribe has to face and this is not
hunting dove with a gun this is hunting
a lion with a spear hmm by yourself by
yourself yeah yeah
now I will say spoiler alert
probably an incorrect use of the term at
this point they don't do this anymore
because of government restrictions on
lion hunting it's and there's the lion
population isn't what it used to be that
sounds like a good thing but so but
listen for everyone in let's go back to
whenever this was still a legal thing
they would send a boy out with a spear
Wow and you had to kill a lion have used
have you seen have you seen a lion have
you like been you men to the zoo you've
seen a lion
yes sir
I have I've seen many lions in many
different screens and what a person it
they're always kind of sleeping at the
zoo and they're also hard to see at the
zoo but I was always kind like the rock
sleeping oh yeah I wouldn't want to have
to sneak around that rock with a stick
with just something pointy on the end
and think I was gonna win this scenario
on the other side well this was no zoo
this was just the plains hey you just I
mean I've seen it there's a YouTube
video of a guy like a really old video
and one of those dudes dressed up in
like a classic like colonial you know
jungle suit and he's shooting a lion
with a gun that's charging in like a
high-powered rimy like a safari Safari
suit not a colonial suit whatever I
pictured a pilgrim mile in the Savannah
you know I'm talking about like the
colonial times like the way that the
guys would go out and like colonize like
other places but I was thinking a java
safari suit and the this thing he kills
this line with a gun and it's just it's
crazy but he had a gun again this these
dudes had a spear I mean they were a boy
they were a boy when they went out like
sent him to lock out there with a spear
and saying come back and I want you to
have killed a lion it and they did it
they did it this would not have
continued to be a rite of passage for
many years apparently they were
relatively successful because this is
how you become a man and this is back in
the day when there were a lot of lions
and so this wasn't thinning out the
population now the way they do it is
they send people out in group groups of
ten and you can come back with I think
the government hair from a lion you
don't have to actually kill a lion well
no just like trim a little hair off the
lion's mane and that'll count well no
the Lions are protected it doesn't mean
that they can't kill them it just means
that they have to only kill a certain
number of them and so they send them out
in groups of ten and the guy who
actually is the one who successfully
Spears the lion who throws the first
spear that kills the light okay so
because I mean there's this again
there's YouTube videos of this happening
of like multiple dudes like going up
killing a line in crazy intense videos
but the first guy throws the spirit
killed
and kills aalayam he gets to wear the
lion's mane as a prize trophy and he
officially becomes a man but they kind
of understand listen we can't won't I'll
be your main man Oh everybody can't kill
a lion and so I guess it isn't that no
one everyone is a man it's just that the
dude who actually is the one to do it
and the main means the main man exactly
yeah I don't even know if I I don't even
want to watch a video of that but I
certainly would respect any 10 or 12 or
13 year old who who had speared a lion I
mean that Garner's a lot of respect from
me for what that's worth I don't know
then we move on to Bulls yeah I got some
Bulls here for it
jumping over bulls and this one gets
even better no while completely naked
now this is a rite of passage that are
read about performed by men of the
Hammar tribe of southern Ethiopia before
they are allowed to get married okay so
if you really want to get married
you got to line some bulls up and you
got to get naked now as with a lot of
these rite of passage ceremonies just
picture air it's a big deal for everyone
who lives in your town or village or
whatever you want to call it and not
only that but you've got family members
and friends coming from far-off other
villages to come in to witness this rite
of passage naked the thing that strikes
me is first of all the pressure
associated with something like this I
mean culturally it's set up that every
year people perform these rites of
passages and then as you're growing up
you know that okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
make the passage one year and in this
particular zone it involves lining up
bulls but first all of the female
friends and family members of the boy
soon-to-be man get together and they are
whipped by the men of the tribe this is
part of the ceremony and the scars that
are on the backs of the of the women I
mean they stay there for the rest of
their lives they're kind of like a badge
of honor to test to testify to the pain
that they are willing to endure for the
initiate so if it's their son initiate I
don't know if that's the right word the
person who's initiated I like initiate
and you know you'd say well this is this
is a sad byproduct of this thing that
women are being whipped but actually
what I read said that it was a strange
form of empowerment because the women
are belittling the men who are whipping
them and kind of like talking trash to
are talking trash to him and say you're
too feeble to whip me hard enough to
hurt me and they're not acting like
they're being hurt this is I mean this
is their part in the rite of passage
yeah that's just part of it and then
they bring out the Bulls and they line
them up these are castrated bulls that
are lined up so steer these are steer
okay if you want to get technical in
they're lined up side by side like
picture a bunch of bulls I'm from the
video I saw we're talking like five
mm-hm and it's it's if you're trying to
get them all bunched in together for a
picture like okay steer we're gonna take
a nice group photo for your for your
class you need to get in a little bit
closer so they're all facing the camera
so to speak
right and and there's people holding
them in place and then the person the
boy soon to be man is naked like right
just buck naked yeah or bull of naked
the Bulls are also a Bulls are complete
say that there's no Bucks involved yeah
and then he runs and he jumps up on the
first cow and then and then starts to
pitter-patter across them like legolas
on the top of snow hmm from the other
side and then he goes it falls down on
the other side and then people that's it
people cheer nope you're a man nope you
got to do it three more times what is it
what is the risk involved you can
lipping between steer slipping deer
slippage yep that is that is the I don't
want to get you don't want to slip and
get stuck between steer right if you
complete the task you're a man and if
you get steer slippage I don't know what
happens if they if they let you keep
going well steer slippage when naked
it's probably a more serious business
than like steer slippage when full
clothes I mean there's a lot of pressure
involved because it's not easy to
balance barefoot on the top of cows who
are just standing there I mean I assume
they practice this in you know in the
privacy of their own pastures but you
know you've got your your friends and
relatives who are being whipped on your
behalf
yeah there's there's a lot of pressure
here and then you're then you're strip
down the you nothing and then you've got
to balance on these bulls I mean we've
jumped over a cow but we weren't naked
and well technically it was two cows it
was but you're gonna tell that story but
the cow wasn't it was dead and I didn't
I didn't really consider the right of
passage but it was but it's a memory
it's a heck of a great memory so I'll
consider it in retrospect this is a
former rite of passage now that I know
about it and I think there was something
that's instinctual within us that led us
to try to do this just to give you some
background after school I mean this is
like early high school maybe we
definitely had our licenses we were like
sixteen years early you think we were
that old down there there was a cow
pasture that was adjacent to that always
rode rode my bike down there okay the
golf course that you know we would we
would play on as kids with Ben Greenwood
our other friend and we'd jump go across
the creek to we've actually told this
story on something but yeah we have yeah
we chase the cows see again again this
is why we don't just tell stories
because we've told you all the stories
before but we would chase the cows and
it's just thrilling to chase cows that
does make you feel like you have power
over a whole herd of beasts it kind of
makes you like a man
one day we go out there and we see in
the distance there's a there's a berm
that's not usually there and as we get
closer it is a dead cow laying on its
side and it is bloated yeah yes Bree and
it was really nasty because the it was a
mama cow who died while giving birth and
the baby cow was halfway out yeah
halfway out in the baby this is a
shocking thing the baby cow was also
dead yeah this is a shocking thing to
come upon so I remember there was a
teenager there was a sense that we
needed to kind of whisper being in the
presence of this dead calf yeah and it
was I'm pretty fresh I would say I don't
remember it was a somber moment because
it was a
it was almost like an introspective
moment for us and we sat there and kind
of looked at each other and we talked
quietly and it was like this is
seriously did some forensic Zen out here
chasing these cows for years and now
here this cow lays dead having given
birth and died and the new life died
like we were being overly poetic for
like 15 year-olds or whatever we were
and then a couple of minutes pass and we
start jumping over it yeah yeah well
what happened was in the member the
silence was broken with someone saying
you think we can jump over and then we
just backed up and started running
full-speed and hurt jumping over it like
it was a hurdle yeah and we did
successfully several times because there
was substantial risk and pressure I
would say you don't want to get uploaded
cam you don't want to land in the middle
of a cow you don't want that kind of
slippage to happen and we were not naked
maybe we should have been yeah that
would have made it more interesting I
guess and that's why I'm still not a man
because I wasn't naked when that
happened but I'm maybe there's something
within us it was like okay there's risk
here so if we do it within the presence
of each other we're proving something
and that's kind of what's behind these
rites of passages as we move on to the
next one that you know you're
demonstrating bravery or an ability to
endure pain yeah and and it's a
demonstration a willingness to and
there's a camaraderie of people have
gone through these things that then
you're joining the ranks of people
who've gone through it yeah it's well
and I've made a couple of comments I
mean number one we're not our role our
you know our angle and talking about
these things is not to judge them or try
to say or to try to endorse them and say
that was what we should we should be
doing or they shouldn't be doing it or
whatever it's just to tell you guys
about them it wouldn't have a little fun
talking about it but also yeah this is a
totally don't these things only exist in
more isolated cultures that are still
kind of holding on to longtime
traditions exactly for the reason that
you were talking about because if you go
to a certain tribe like if you go to
this next tribe the satyr a my way tribe
in Brazil you know that every man in
this tribe which is currently at 10,000
members there was only 80
guys in this 88 people in this in the
1970s really
but now there's 10,000 people in this
tribe you know that every man in this
tribe has undergone this incredibly
painful rite of passage that we're gonna
talk about and that means something it's
like if I meet I'm from North Carolina
if I meet somebody from Washington I
just know okay you're from the US also
but there's not a connection with oh you
did this thing where you stuck your hand
inside the bullet ant glove is so tell
me so this is the bullet ant glove now
I've heard a little bit of this this has
been on a number of television shows and
there's a few YouTube videos showing
people do this so you may have seen this
one but this is essentially when they
this tribe makes their the Saturday my
way tribe makes their makes their young
boys wear gloves filled with bullet ants
while they dance for 10 minutes without
flinching bullet and yes the bullet ants
have the most painful sting of any
insect any insect so I mean you're
talking alike biggest bumblebee craziest
Hornet you can imagine worse than that
so this thing is a 4 plus rating on the
Schmidt sting pain index which is a
thing Schmidt sting pain and so glad
that there is a sting pain index and
that it's called the Schmidt sting pain
because it makes it so difficult to
pronounce yeah and I could just imagine
how it figured this out Schmidt just sat
around and stung himself with with
multiple things I guess I'm so that's
gonna give this one a four plus they
call it the locals call it the 24-hour
ant referring to the full day of pain
that follows being stung so here's what
they do they render the ants unconscious
by submerging them in a natural sedative
and then hundreds of them are woven into
a glove made out of leaves which
basically looks like a large oven mitt
Stinger facing inward so you you know
it's like you got all these ants
stingers facing your hand and then they
the ants begin to regain consciousness
and they slip the boy's hand into the
glove and then the goal of the
initiation rite is to keep the glove on
for a full 10 minutes 10 minutes now let
me just
quickly give you something as a point of
reference you may have heard of the
Australian comedy duo Hamish and Andy
they did this one I don't I don't know
which one of them did this there's a
YouTube video it's got about 6 million
views of showing them do this but one of
them that's not enough views to do it
sticks his hand into the mitt and pulls
it out almost immediately like he sticks
it in there he reacts he pulls his hands
out and then for the next few hours he
is an intense debilitating pain like
he's lost to the world crazy and the
boys of the actual tribe they put it in
there for 10 minutes and they don't just
do it once what they will go through
this ordeal a total of about 20 times
over the course of several months or
even years as part of the initiation
rites to become a warrior and so what
they do if once you put your hands in
there for 10 minutes your hands it's so
painful you can't take it right you have
to get around and you dance the way they
you know sometimes like when we do
something real painful on GMM like you
kind of need a reaper you feel like you
got to want something got at least wall
so they actually have a dance that is
part of this like you it's just built in
yeah get stung you got your mitts on and
you do a dance with everybody and then
he bunts it the his hands are so
overwhelmed with venom that his hands
become paralyzed but then once they
start hurting again you shake
uncontrollably for a few days for a few
days whole body shakes yes just tremors
of pain yeah I mean that you'll be in
intense pain for 24 hours and then for
the next couple days after that you'll
have you'll still be having a little
shudders I wonder if it will kill you I
mean I got to think that it could I'm
sure there's a risk maybe somebody could
have a reaction to it but yeah that's
that's what they do that's how they
become men I mean the my brother jump
over some Cal's yeah the more intense
the shared experience that the the the
greater the effect I think on the
community then you know especially to
become a warrior I mean you you kind of
want to pass a threshold of pain and
to be entrusted as like a warrior in
your community I mean you think about
Navy SEAL training which has a
reputation of being extreme and you know
they design everything so that you can
drop out at any moment they even
encourage trainees all along the way
they're they're they're berating them
they're constantly giving them outs to
get out of it because they don't they
want to weed people out because then
they know that you know as hard as it
was you had every opportunity to check
out but those who made it through
there's there's a bond that you know I
guess lead leads to effective wartime
strategy well and you got to think that
in a interesting byproduct of this type
is such an intense initiation ritual
that you can't avoid you've got to think
I don't know the statistics on this
that's that probably every every person
in every man at least ends up doing it
which is an incredible thing to think I
mean it says that in order to become a
warrior so I get I would think that the
people who had not gone through this
would be less the guy that couldn't do
the bullet ant thing he refused to do it
in our culture if you don't want to do
something uncomfortable you just don't
do it and there's no judgment and that's
that's fine that's the way it is in our
culture it's a totally different thing
in the Western world but in this culture
it's like you can't avoid this you're on
a straight trajectory towards the bullet
ant glove if you're a male and then you
have to do it in order to get to the
next stage
that's an interesting dynamic but but I
can't avoid it I would imagine that it's
tempered by the fact that from a very
young age from your earliest memories
you're aware of this rite of passage and
it becomes something that you're
conditioned to expect so it's it's not
like you're an Australian comedian who
just decides two days earlier to do it
right you know you spent your whole life
being invested in this thing your young
life and then finally this day is here
I'm looking forward to this I this means
something to me into my
community and you know those are those
are factors that can really charge
motivations large motivations you know I
mean we tend to be motivated I'm gonna
get into this vat of ice and I'm very
scared but I'm gonna do it because hey
it's entertaining is what the mythical
beasts have come to expect and you know
my livelihood is now attached to the
mean entertaining in this way but it's
I'm I'm doing I've done a lot of stuff
that I would never do if cameras weren't
rolling I say that all the time yeah but
this goes would you do this because it's
so much more meaningful what I do this
because this is the real question out
there a comedic duo has already done it
hey but whenever it is long but when I
watched oh really you want you're gonna
go full ten minutes I don't go one
second longer than that guy when I watch
this it made me think and I don't even
want to say it out loud but it's made me
think that like oh I could totally see
us doing a series like this we go around
and do all this ridiculous stuff but
then I just said I should not think that
thought because I just value comfort too
much all right let's weigh it against
this next scenario that I got here we've
been to Kenya Ethiopia and Brazil but
now let's come back to North America to
North Dakota specifically where the man
Don reside that's the Mandan Native
American tribe their exact origin and
history is unknown but ethnologist
theorized they originated in the area of
the mid-mississippi River or the Ohio
river valleys and migrated north to
North Dakota between the 7th and 13th
century so that's your little background
this is a tough group let me ask you if
I'd you right from the ceiling daughter
row don't ever drink on me dangle you
from the ceiling with a rope under your
armpits okay not bad and drove stakes
into your chest and back not pieces of
meat just like pieces of like sharp wood
okay the difference do you think you
would a sign up for this at a young age
and be keep a smile on your face the
whole time smile the whole time smiled
I don't think I would be smiling at any
time well if you wanted to be a leader
the Mandan tribe
you better be smiling pretty buddy
now this was a powerful one this intense
powerful religious ceremony of the
Mandan people called Okita okay and it
was the culmination of a four-day
ceremony performed annually during the
summer which basically retold the story
of the creation of the earth from their
perspective okay so just picture a big
tent with dancers inside performing and
there's the men of the village of
fasting and praying and seeking visions
mm-hmm and the younger men were the ones
who generally underwent torture to
demonstrate their bravery all right
that's this rite of passage in the Akiba
they had long wooden skewers pushed
through cuts in their skin on their
backs and chests but he's like kebab
sticks are they probably bigger well I'm
looking at a picture here and it just
just picture like mini Spears it's just
like acupuncture on like a Native
American level like way way beyond and
then they string ropes up under their
shoulders under their armpits and hang
them from beams and then their bodies
are weighed down with Buffalo skulls
what which are hung from more skewers
that are thrust into their thighs in
their cab oh no I can handle that and I
mean obviously the torment of this was
extreme but crying out was a sign of
cowardice
you couldn't cry you couldn't grimace
the ones who were best able to stand the
pain became the leaders was it you're
smiling so we're Somalian Jack he's the
next leader so did you just was that
just a twist of your own the whole thing
about smiling or was that actually part
of it like but it's happier you seen why
you did it I added I added smiling okay
but that probably would have been a nice
touch
those who were best able to withstand
the paint so the one who could muster a
smile was certainly the one who was who
was a top notch leader at least a corner
to my understanding I will say that I
that I've always thought that that is
that's a sign of it somebody who's tough
is that you their pain doesn't register
on their face like somebody who's really
really tough like that you look at them
in your life he doesn't seem like he's
in that much pain and there's some
people you look at him you're like their
face looks like it's a it's a sign of
all the things that are going wrong in
their body right now and then some
people just have resting pain face
slightly it's like man is he like
barefoot stepping on broken bottles no
that's just that's just a look on its
face resting painful face resting pain
face it's got a cousin face which we
don't need to talk about the this a
kippah rite of passage is not performed
anymore I mean it was suppressed by the
US government so it was thought that the
last ceremony was held between 1889 and
1890 on the Fort Berthold Reservation so
this ain't happening anymore but I'm
looking at a painting by George Catlin
in 1832 of this thing and it's just I
can't imagine just stepping in as a you
know kind of a researcher slash artist
and witnessing this from the outside
especially with the language barriers
like what's going on are they being
executed or something no they are
becoming men it's amazing I just it just
makes me wonder like what would you know
again I go back to because we are we
live in a culture where you can just get
out of stuff that you don't like like
were there people who were like I don't
want to be a part of this and then he
became like an outcast I like I don't
know but I'd like to think that there I
mean that that there still was a to each
his or her own type of a thing that they
didn't or probably not yeah I don't know
it probably wasn't man they probably
that's probably had not how it was the
Fulani people he heard of those people
no well can I interest you in a whipping
match no I don't think so well if you
remember of the Fulani people of Africa
I could
I'm talking about a couple of boys
lashing each other with sharpened sticks
now my kids fight a lot mostly mostly it
starts as a game mm-hmm and it usually
ends with somebody cry somebody crying
and listen 11 year old and a six year
old you would usually think that the six
year old is the one that ends up crying
which is very often the case but not
every time some tough six year old yeah
and what do you give them sticks with
like shards on the I do not it's all
kinds of things so often pillows but the
Fulani people do take things a few steps
further a gripping match is basically a
ritual in which two different kids two
different boys who are they volunteer
they say I'm ready to become a man I'm
ready for my whipping match though
there's a there's a interesting video a
National Geographic that kind of shows
this this happening in the sense that I
get is that the Fulani people are a very
widely dispersed people they're not just
like a small village that all live
together there's this is like a large
group of people and they have okay a lot
of different villages but they all do
this ritual and these whiffing matches
so they'll take a kid from one of the
villages and they'll take another kid
from the other village and they'd say
like my kids ready my kids ready all
right let's put them together so they
pit two kids from two different villages
against one another and when they do see
that like home town rivalry do they both
win or does all any one and only one of
them gets become a man only one winner
yeah it didn't in the video though in
manhood at the end whether you know it
or lose no I think I don't know if the
other dude has to go back and do it
again but here's what you're trying to
do you take your shirt off you're not
naked but you don't have a shirt on and
you have with the help of your father
and your brothers and other men in your
life you've you've selected a stick and
you've sharpened the end of it and this
is just like a eight foot long
just stick 8 foot stick
they can get you know you get a lot of
leverage with that kind of thing
and all these people come out to watch
you you stink you so the guy who goes
first one guy goes out into the middle
and he puts his arms above his head oh
no there's not a fight they just take
turns and then you get to hit the dude
three times with your stick and they hit
them on the side the ribs and it reaches
around and grabs the flesh off of the
side of the front this is intense
I mean it's Covidien National Geographic
just intense until you historically this
has been done to prisoners across many
societies and it's it's it's as a far as
a punish it's a horrifying thing to
think about
much less witness but to but to witness
it and then volunteer for it
Wow so this is what happens you you
inflict three whips and then you have
three whips inflicted upon you and the
crowd judges who took it better so let
me tell you right now the video that I
watched of these two kids who looked to
be about 13 14 years old they both took
it a whole lot better than I would have
I mean there was so little flinching
there was no crying and they got whipped
hard no crying very little flinching but
they just it was like kind of obvious to
the crowd that one kid had flinched less
and they come out and they reward him
and they they throw talcum powder all
over you and they put gold coins on your
for it I don't think the baby powder is
worth it honestly but maybe the manhood
being considered a man is so I'm just
you know I just I just feel sorry for
him but that's just maybe that's just
out of ignorance maybe it's just from my
different collection perspective it's a
different culture if you were to take
without that I don't understand MMA
fighting like I can tell whenever that
like whenever I go to a restaurant like
we go to a sushi restaurant that for
some reason they they always put MMA
fighting
on there and I you know I don't have
cable it doesn't come on screens in my
life so I haven't developed an interest
in it MMA fighting does not come on
screens in your life and then so when I
see it at the sushi restaurant which is
just not a great place to see it you
know there'll be seeing raw flesh on my
plate why yeah that's a horrible
combination I don't get it I asked him
to change it to basketball one time
basketballs not great during that during
the tournament but I'm always struck is
it you know having not seen MMA for a
while I'm like man this is brutal and
but the thing that always gets me when
I'm seeing it for the first time is that
at the end there's like a guy who who
taps out and then there's a guy who wins
and there it's like there's no winner
here is no way that I feel about but the
guy's so elated and he's trained so hard
for this and he's you know it's not
really that different except he's 12
years old and to me that's one big
difference well and like would we be
watching MMA for thirteen year olds
that's kind of what this is you might if
you were in this culture one of the
interesting differences and with this
one is that it doesn't happen at a
certain age it's about the rituals
conducted once a boy feels he is ready
to become a man which is an interesting
I wonder if that's always where your own
boy feels like he's ready so it is
voluntary but again the same thing that
you said if you were to take
thirteen-year-old rhett and Link and
make them have a whipping match against
one another that would be cruel and
unusual right but for this these guys
who this is what they know this is this
is a cultural thing for them they just
they just step right up to the plate and
do it it does remind me of the ten year
old rhett and Link that would whenever I
like come over to her sleep over at your
house and we would we take the cassette
tapes and weed stuff papers in the top
and we'd make your hoardings or
ridiculous recordings playing different
characters that was our form of YouTube
way back in the 80s but one of the other
games we invented we only played it one
night Oh was he had this Rhett had this
ball and it was like I don't even
remember what kind of ball it was but it
like a baseball sized ball but it was
mushy ER and nice I think it was the
incredible I don't know what that is it
was small it was it was like a baseball
sized ball yeah yeah yeah the
Incrediball I think that's what it's
called is a bouncy it's a baseball
designed for like kids so it's I
remember it's like cloth and rubbery I
remember it being slightly mushy ER than
what I think that would be but anyway we
decided to get on opposite sides of your
room which was a very small room I mean
we're talking I cannot believe you're
telling this story and then we would
just throw we said all right we're gonna
throw the ball at each other's balls and
see who can take it like we'll take
turns I'm gonna throw it at your balls
and you see if you can take I mean we
were fully clothed
yeah like but we really tried we're
sitting across from each other that
elects opposite sides of the room
rolling the ball at each other yeah we
rolled it that's right we didn't we
rolled the ball like bowling ball style
and it's Turkish who could you know it
wasn't it was another we had a device
against a man who I haven't thought
about this in a long time and so we're
doing it and I'm sure we're like
groaning and laughing and giggling and
being Complete Idiot's like we still are
and then the door no no the first thing
I hear is the sound of my father coming
up the stairs and my dad had a little
bit of a quick fuse so I knew that there
was there there was no like hey guys
quiet down there was it just went from
hearing nothing to coming up the stairs
BAM the door swings out front he opens
the door he's standing there he's got on
a v-neck white t-shirt underwear and his
socks that he had worn to work like Navy
socks like pulled up a little bit he was
a boxer man he was waiting box really
wasn't he wearing briefs you had you
picture him and wearing box cuz I never
want to picture briefs in my mind
whenever was briefs huh so he was like
Walter white out in the desert exactly
season want to break him in and then he
just looks like this I know what he said
just what the hell are you doing what he
said
and remember boats just look at it and I
was
so afraid especially because I was
thinking what what do you say we were
throwing a ball at each other's balls
they say there's nothing you can say I
mean we're both spread-eagle with a ball
in our hand giggling and he busted in
the room it said he knows what we're
doing we're throwing a ball at each
other's nuts
and I was like oh nothing will be quiet
and he's like okay I need to walk back
downstairs I think when he opened the
door in his anger and he said that then
he saw like the configuration we were in
it's like it's it's as if he was then
thinking you know what I don't want to
know I don't want to know I don't even
want to know but I think the larger
observation here besides the fact that I
have no idea what impact this is going
to have on us the fact that you've told
this story publicly now is you're right
we invented a test of manhood and if we
were like isolated in like some part of
the world and and there was like us and
like 50 other people we might say you
know what the way you find out if you're
a man is use you sit across from each
other and you roll in Incrediball at
each other's balls that could be then
that's could be how things get started I
think that's called a cult I'm just
saying if we did it it would be a cult
but you see how these things get started
and then it's just like yeah I you know
my dad and my dad's dad and now me have
all took the credit ball to the balls
well that brings me to an interesting
one this next one I have has an
interesting backstory which the has it's
a legend which led to this rite of
passage practice which you may have seen
on on television on the different Nat
Geo type scenarios Discovery Channel
have you I lead a sheltered life so I
really hadn't seen this yet so I'm gonna
talk to all of you out there who've
never heard of this but maybe you
haven't heard of the legend that went
into it we're going to the southern part
of Pentecost Island to Vanuatu okay
which a season of Survivor was there yes
so you know is awesome place if survivor
than a house season
right maybe let me ask you a question to
get into this one would you have a
bungee jump Rhett yes no or if cameras
were there yes if cameras were there but
no otherwise I don't think I would just
do it for fun no I agree
would you ever bungee jump using Tarzan
vines strapped to your legs instead of
an actual bungee cord
if cameras were there no because I do
know what you're talking about now and I
have seen this on the television 100
feet in the air
Tarzan vines and that's my terminology
strapped to their feet that's not what
they call it
it's called land diving known as Nicole
and it's done by the Vanuatu people as a
ritual associated with the annual yam
harvest they don't do it for cameras
they don't do it for accolades they do
it for the yams okay that's a good are
good and when you reach it they're very
good for food and when you reach a
certain age you get to enter into this
practice is it easy is it sweet potato
casserole or is it just sweet potatoes
its yams okay they do and make
everything out of them okay here's the
backstory legend is a sweet potato
casserole with marshmallows on top I
might do it
legend has it that a woman was
dissatisfied with her husband whose name
was tamale likely story
she was so sad dissatisfied with tamale
that she ran away from him into the
forest but tamale pursued her so she
climbed a banyan tree which is Daltry in
Vanuatu well up he goes after her
climbing so she ties lianna's which are
vines
mm-hmm to her ankles and jumps to get
away from him
she art she survives you know she
invented bungee jumping legend has it
her husband in hot pursuit jumps after
her but he misses the crucial step of
tying Liana's to himself that is
important so he pretty much the only
important thing he died okay he does
splat tamale
I thought this is the origin story of
tamales no but that's it that's
different
no it is named as tamale right that's
just it so now in this the legend is
that now the men because they certainly
perform this ritual annually now that it
was it originated this land I've been
originated so that men would not be
tricked again into you know to follow
the fate of tamale so the timing is good
yam harvest is a dry season which makes
it a good time to build this huge Tower
it's also the time of year when the
Liana's are that have the most
elasticity which is key it's the natural
bungee cord
it takes them between two and five weeks
to build this tower 20 to 30 min
constructing it cutting trees down to
construct the body clearing a site
removing rocks from the soil I mean a
lot goes into this thing and they do
this and they don't just leave the same
structure up they do it every time they
rebuild it yeah that's my understanding
and the lowest platform is about ten
meters there which is okay ten meters
that's high that's like you jump into
water off of ten meters and that's a
scary thing right the highest platform
near the top we're talking 100 feet
which you can do the conversions of
mixing measurements here during the jump
the platform supports snap on purpose
causing the platform to hinge downward
and absorb some of the force so they got
this thing down to a science and vines
are selected by village elders and
matched with each jumpers weight so like
like an old guy who's got like a lot of
experience like you need this vine
because you looked away 184 pounds not
very precise he's just fine there ain't
no there's not a blackboard with some
like calculations or some TI 82 yeah
there's you know we have one of those in
his back pocket younger boys jump as a
rite of passage starting from the lowest
platform which 10 meters we're talking
like two storeys high jumping jumping
into this thing more than that
10 meters I mean your son has three
stories three stories well
they may start a little bit lower than
that and then you know the event goes on
men start jumping from higher and higher
platforms in the final man you know
jumps from 100 feet now here's the thing
you've strapped these vines to your feet
your your bungee jumping off your head
has to hit the ground in order for it to
take for an order for what to take the
yams in order for the yams to be blessed
Oh got it
your your head has to hit the ground so
as you launch yourself off you hope that
whoever cut those vines cut them just
right if they're too short and your head
doesn't hit the ground yams all gonna be
blessed you'll live but the yams if the
vine is too long and I'm talking four
inches too long you'll die but the yams
will be blessed okay so that's good to
know at least you don't die for nothing
right so you become a man you would get
to enter into this and then you just
keep doing it for the sake of the yams
now the thing I watched that on a bumper
sticker by the way do it for the singham
do it for the amps are t-shirt I think
the thing I watched about this you know
on one of those channels that show stuff
like this years ago the impression I got
in watching it was that it is very very
rare for someone to die doing this well
I watched I watched a YouTube clip of a
guy any few snap the thing the vine
snaps you see it snap and he just hits
the ground from a hundred feet and then
everybody runs up to him and he hit a
they did they build it on a slope so
when your head hits the ground it's not
just splat it's on a slope
you got a roll that helped because he
just stood up and started cheering so it
kind of undermined or they blessed
probably when I saw probably I think
that counts I'm if I'm the guy who was
in charge that counts I mean that is a
good climb the guys in charge would
probably stop doing this and probably
just like get fertilizer but you know
what
no charge I'm not in charge do they have
your email or your cell phone no they
may be that's why they haven't called
you they want you to be in charge
they just haven't called you I you know
the in the thing is is that you say
elasticity is important but from the
videos that I've watched they're not
very elastic we're not talking about
actual elastic we're not talking about
bungee cords where the thing goes to
like five times its length or whatever
we're talking about a vine that may
stretch a little bit because it was a
little bit bent in one place I think
it's cool that the platform gives away
and adds that level of wonkiness
yeah you know the pointyness is key that
the the honed engineering that goes into
this thing I would love to go and watch
it I would certainly buy a ticket to
watch but you wouldn't do it no and I
wouldn't stand right underneath him
either this is one I'm not saying I
would do any of these but this is one
that you know the yams are gonna have to
die I'm not doing this I'm not
interested I'll do the bullet ant before
I do this will you do this next week I I
don't know let's go let's Anna let's go
through the details once more the
Matisse
hunting trials the Matisse tribe I think
I'm saying that right is in Brazil and a
boy is not a man until he can
participate in a hunt oh okay sure he's
got a got a hunt no no no no you can't
hunt unless we do a series of things to
you a series of unpleasant things okay
the first thing they do to the boy is
they put poison into his eyes which is
supposed to improve his vision oh really
yeah
got some poison in your eyes that rub it
in there it's bitter is this is like a
long-term positive effect in a
short-term negative effect apparently
but that's just step one the second step
is they beat you and with you is a
series of beatings and whippings I guess
from the other guys that you're about to
go out hunting with
and then lastly you are injected with
poison frog goop
they have defined frog goop
you know like poison frogs have like
nasty poison on their skin and in these
glands and stuff and they you see so you
scrape it they get the poison off with
squeezing wooden like needles and then
they inject you with these this poison
again yes and this poison is supposed to
increase your strength and your
endurance but not until it has also
caused projectile vomiting and intense
diarrhea they basic which I almost kill
you I don't typically associate
projectile vomiting in intense diarrhea
with strength and endurance but if you
can exhibit strengthen endurance while
projectile vomiting and and all of that
then you've earned
you've earned a ranking higher than me
on the man scale well I'm just trying to
figure out again doesn't count for much
I guess
you know I'm trying to figure out the
origin of this one right because I have
a feeling that they got together at one
time and they were like what are we
gonna do to make sure a boy is a man
before he goes hunting take the worst
things no exist in our environment and
inject them into your person your eyes
right well that's when they ended up but
it was like one guy said let's put the
poison in his eyes and he was like
that's a good idea all right let me
write that down let's just beat him
let's just beat him and whip him several
times okay I don't let me let me put
that on the white boy pencil it in um
okay what about those we got those
poison frogs we let's take some of that
poison you know every herb ate one of
those frogs a few days ago and he had
projectile vomiting and intense diarrhea
why don't we just take some of the
poison and just inject it right in there
okay well let me help
all right let's write this down all
right who thinks that bitter poison in
the eyes is a good ideas everybody
raises their hand what about the
beatings in the whippings they all raise
their hand and frog the Alvarez a hint
okay we'll do all of it yeah it's like
they were having a brainstorming session
and then if there were no wrong answers
forgot that they were only going to
choose one
and they just they like slept on it went
back to the whiteboard and said oh was
it to work the works done and of course
the man came up with it because they
were like we're Arnie guy we're all
right we already hunt you know obviously
they are there ones who came up boys
there were no boys in the room at the
time hold on can we just do one of these
so that's what it takes to be a man and
a hunter and the matisse tribe in Brazil
I'm not signing up for that one either I
don't think I'm signing up for any of
these I mean I in retrospect you know if
we analyze our touch points for like
throwing stuff on our own reproduction
for organs or jumping over dead cows
it's like we are great we're grasping
yeah we're grasping at manhood right
well I would go as far as to say that
Sam we're not men I I mean I I would go
as far as to say that by the standards
they if we were to go and hang out with
any of these people groups we would not
be considered men what makes a man mr.
Lebowski I think about that like that in
a pair of testicles um I always felt
like getting my own car is the is the
closest like um and this is kind of a
this is a commentary perhaps a sad one
it's like getting my own car was a rite
of passage
you know there's independence associated
with definitely and at age 16 is but
where we come from right so it's it's a
little bit older it's interesting today
there are lots of sixteen year olds who
could care less about getting a car
because in the digital age I'm told it
is just not that much of a getting a car
is not arriving because you've traveled
the world in the internet there's
something psychological there i I've the
trend of kids not getting cars but I
will say that at least for us doubt oh
it was that was huge that was the right
of past life more than over the cow you
know I know I know kids these days who
do not immediately get their their
license when they're eligible but for me
it was like
October 11th my birthday you ain't lying
I'm at the DMV like I've been thinking
about this day for years I don't I don't
under I cannot relate I cannot relate to
why you would be like oh I'll do that
I'll wait I'll wait to get my license
I'm not saying I'm just saying I'm
giving you my perspective well I'm not
prescribing anything no but for me it
was shooting a gun with your dad I think
that there's something to that you know
when I turned 16 we had the big birthday
party my dad cooked a pig at my aunt T
C's house right every I was one of the
last ones that turned 16 so everyone had
their own car and then I remember I got
in my truck my 1987 Nissan pickup and
unlike old heat up at the time didn't
have the license plate on it yet no it
doesn't my mind I listen to some Charlie
Daniels and we drove around and I
remember we had the party they were like
what are we gonna do is that we're gonna
drive around we have this power now we
have this on taco anywhere we won't a
lonely road and then no everyone got
into their own car and there was like no
one was together anymore we were just
like a bunch of we're like a parade
going down country roads just not it
wasn't caravanning caravanning into into
the rest of our lives loving every
minute of it I mean when I got my
license because I got a little bit
earlier than you just October before
June I picked you up and we just went on
some different around some dirt roads it
was exhilarating
you know in a what will make ax we were
in the Oldsmobile Omega just we're in
this like 1981 sedan going around on
dirt roads why because we could cuz we
were men rest and then you know you get
married or you have children and those
are milestones that well maybe now I'm a
man like I'm responsible for other
people's lives like these kids who need
to be fed a feel more mannish now
because I feel like if I fail
somebody could die and people are
depending on you now right but there was
you know it would I would step I would
have stepped in that more confidently if
I had ingested frog poison
or balanced on some cows in front of my
loved ones who had been whipped you know
it would be more definitive it was
definitely more definitive I do think
and I think this is an application at
least for myself I'm gonna noodle on
this okay I'll put this out there for
food for thought
as parents of kids who are approaching
you know they're in adolescence week I
got a 12 year old daughter and uh it's
not I'm talking about both of them
becoming adults it's not just about
being a man Babu but getting closer to
an adult right creating something
special for each of my children and I
know people who have done this it's kind
of like a a rite of passage in a way
that it's like okay this weekend is
about your your your 13 or your 16 or
whatever creating an experience that
they can kind of hold on to there's
maybe there's something written and
there's a love doesn't have to be
bleeding involved what book but I mean
obviously as we think about it in 2015
United States or pain would have to be
paid we're gonna like create like a cool
camping trip and a plaque or something
but what if there it what if we do break
out the bullet ant glove or something
like a mild version of that well we'd be
like taking to jail man or what about it
like an ice bath like that was traumatic
for me on I am a that's not I think
that's that's a good one
I I think a heartfelt letter maybe a
signet ring I know be cool I think
something that is physically challenging
mm-hmm you could signify something so
like a whitewater rafting trip why no
well that would be fun but I'm talking
about like well I'm thinking about I
want to do it to making it to the top of
Half Dome or something like that you
know just something that's difficult
that's good I feel like we should create
you know we should do link this is what
we should do it's probably already been
done we should create a curriculum as a
rite of passage for boys and girls you
create experience everywhere and it's a
it's it's yeah it's it's just different
rites of passage
that you you sign up for with your kids
and they they do it and then we make a
YouTube channel we don't have to do the
YouTube channel part well there is a
website this is not a plug I just found
it it called extreme seal experience
calm extreme seal experia where you
where you go through Navy SEAL training
trained by real Navy SEALs instructors
and you like go through the whole thing
it's in Virginia and one of the
frequently asked questions is will I die
so I'm not sitting my kids do this but
there are people who sign up for this
type of stuff extreme seelix they're not
the only one who does it but that's just
the one that I found but I'm okay so
that's for us to noodle on I think as
we're shutting down this ear biscuit
hopefully we've given you some things to
think about what you know what makes a
man or a woman I think yeah what like we
said at the top yeah we want to
re-emphasize this that for those of you
who thought that we were leaving women
out on purpose we were not we we made a
decision since we were once boys now we
consider ourselves men that we would
focus on the rites of passage
traditionally seen as boys becoming men
we weren't excluding the women because
they're women we were just deciding to
focus on the men because we're men now
the the in fact in doing a little bit of
research for this because I certainly
think about my daughter Lily boy 12 and
some of the things some of the things
that the women have had to go through or
just you know unfortunately horrible
things that they've had to go through
and there's Rhett not really any reward
on the back end it isn't like oh now
you're a woman necessarily it's just you
know abuse but I think yeah it with art
within our culture it's like giving our
kids all of them an opportunity to have
some sort of formative experience as
opposed to just trying to look back on
their life and trying to figure out what
it is that help them transition to the
next stage of life but that you know
something something definitive want to
figure it out as we work on that we
welcome your your input not not only
about that question but about
this episode in general let us know at
rhettandlink hashtag ear biscuits what
you thought about this episode and
feedback for future episodes also make
sure you leave a review on iTunes that's
always helpful if you're on soundcloud
you were able to comment along with us
so your comment correlates to a specific
time in the conversation if you want to
check that out but I think that's it as
far as what we need them to do right
right and that's all we need you to do I
need you to become men and women if you
want to go it's not time bungee jump
build some vines stick your hand into a
bullet ant glove or jump over some
college you can do that too maybe you've
been inspired to take a specific
application for one of these things do
not mention us do not association with
your decision to do it do not mention us
but please film it
hashtag ear biscuit don't do it the
music's been playing for a while say any
you know you they've already hopefully
they clicked away before you before it
before they heard that I'm good
[Music]
[Music]